I've been getting a ton of people
emailing me flipping out that Hillary
Clinton is suggesting that government
intervene to deal with fake news and
that this would be a major free speech
infringement and that this is an example
of how Hillary Clinton is an anti First
Amendment uh sort of authoritarian and I
think the first step in thinking about
this is let's look at what Hillary
Clinton actually did or did not say this
all stems from a speech she gave on
Capitol Hill a few days ago here is what
Hillary Clinton did say about fake news
and foreign propaganda let me just
mention briefly one thread in particular
that should concern all Americans
Democrats Republicans and independents
alike especially those who serve in our
Congress the epidemic of malicious fake
news and false propaganda that flooded
social media over the past year it's now
clear that so-called fake news can have
real-world consequences this isn't about
politics or partisanship lives are at
risk lives of ordinary people just
trying to go about their days to do
their jobs contribute to their
communities it's a danger that must be
addressed and addressed quickly
bipartisan legislation is making its way
through Congress to boost the
government's response to foreign
propaganda and Silicon Valley is
starting to grapple with the challenge
and threat of fake news it's imperative
that leaders in both the private sector
and the public sector step up to protect
our democracy and innocent lives okay so
she does say that there's legislation to
deal with foreign propaganda and that
Silicon Valley in other words that
companies are grappling with the
challenge of fake news from what she's
saying literally she isn't saying
something that suggests an infringement
on free speech by the government if the
government were to designate what is
fake news and what is not fakes new fake
news that would absolutely be disturbing
from a first amendment standpoint when
the government decides what's real news
what are the real news out
and which ones are not the real news
outlets we've seen in other countries
including as I mentioned earlier in
Latin American countries over the last
50 years how that can be incredibly
problematic there are a number of
different things people are reacting to
hear one is the sort of broader context
of the speech that Hillary Clinton gave
up giving some people the impression
that she's blaming fake news for having
lost the election there's no doubt that
fake news was a factor in the election
but there were many other elements at
play including the fact that Hillary
Clinton was a candidate with huge
baggage as we've talked about I don't
think that that's the important aspect
of this to focus on then we get to the
fake news Pat and fake news is a major
problem I've read a ton of articles this
week about fake news outlets and how
they work and it's all incredibly bogus
and disturbing but government getting
involved in any sort of way where they
are curating what is real and not real
news that is hugely problematic but
companies like Facebook saying stories
from web site X or Y are going to be in
a disadvantaged in our algorithm to
prevent them from going viral as easily
those are decisions that companies like
Facebook are absolutely able to make now
we may disagree with Facebook's
editorial policy we may disagree with
the political bent of what a company
like Facebook or Twitter might decide to
prioritize or D legitimize through these
algorithms but that is absolutely
something that they can do yeah i think
there's this question of who should have
the responsibility to sue out to sweat
through what is fake news and what is
real news right because it definitely
isn't the government that would be an
infringement on free speech I think the
websites have a big play in that and I
think it's also just a matter of
personal responsibility checking the
sources and making sure what you see is
valid and when we have such a lack of
media literacy in this country where
people can't even figure out the
difference between opinion and news
programming or supposed opinion in
supposed news programming it's gonna be
really tough to fix the fake news issue
that's really the more relevant question
to me given that the government should
not be in charge of deciding in any in
any way managing real vs fake news how
can we deal with the fake news epidemic
algorithms on websites like Facebook
that is a really really important thing
using human curation by employees at a
con
bunny like Facebook that's a possibility
but of course then you're going to be
subject to the biases of the individuals
that you select and then as you're
suggesting Pat putting some onus on the
users and saying let's encourage users
to flag in block false content but I
don't know I think we've seen that users
are hungry for certain types of
headlines and by definition they are far
less likely to flag articles that real
or fake support their pre-existing
biases as fake news because they want to
believe that stuff it's not so much that
the user should have an onus to flag and
report fake news stories but just to
look at it themselves and see whether or
not they'd believe it to be true I think
that's where it comes down to that's
something that you used to not have to
do as much but now in 2016 it's
something you have to do this is not
something that's going to go away any
time soon when I saw what Hillary
Clinton said it I could see how you
might interpret this is her saying the
government needs to basically take
control of what is real news and what
isn't I didn't see her say that but i
think that the entire fake news
situation is very very concerning and it
should not i want to be clear it should
not be used as a way to limit speech uh
i want to be super clear about that